I'm trying to say this in like the most
nice way possible because of how like I
truly feel you got analysts and guys
like skip that just talk so crazy out on
the media just because they can skip
I've never once asked you to Hype me up
or do anything like that you did that
because you saw what I was doing on the
field I've never want you to jump on my
coattail you're the one that wanted me
on your show to come speak on your show
and I wanted to do my own route because
of your bad ties and who you are I did
not want to be partner with you and
that's just point blank simple so you
could drive whatever narrative whatever
you want to be but a person who's been
all pro for 3 years and however you want
to put it I guess I am not that guy and
I got to do more to be a guy whatever
narrative that drives your boat or
whatever you want to fit